what's your thoughts on tinder
oh i loved it back when it was good
back when there was the
the golden era of tinder what was that
uh before all the losers [ __ ] found
it tinder was this whispered secret
promise
of this app which is there's a there's
an app just for hiccups and you were
like what what no way there's no way
that's true and like it's just
like-minded people because before it was
like plenty of fish uh which is a dating
one i've done that when i was single but
i always felt that felt bad because
that's a dating website and i was i'm
like i don't want to date yeah like
it's also designed and looks very much
like if
the sunday sun made a dating site i know
that aesthetics and user experience
isn't everything but i want you know
tinder feels at least it felt a little
bit more slick
yeah it did and it felt so it was just
and it was so
shallow and it was just so openly
shallow like it was just yeah man you
can read about them but like let's not
kid ourselves what the first law is
like and you just swiped and like it was
a very different experience for men and
women and i know that i'm getting it
from the perspective of like when it fit
i was a zed-less
[ __ ] straight-wide man on it right so
i'm not getting the level of abuse that
like women are getting on but this was
again before all that happened this was
still the exciting times and i remember
just being worried because like everyone
was like it's just a hook-up website i'm
like oh god i don't know how to
i don't think i know how to just hook up
with someone like i've like i'd normally
like date and then build up to it like
what do we do and then i was in
australia and like
match with a girl on it we went out for
a couple of drinks and like it was hard
after like four hours it was like should
we go bang and i was like
huh
and she was like yeah like you want to
go because it's on tinder and i'm like
oh all right yeah oh great and i'm like
man this is i was like it's grinder
because i've got gay friends and grinder
was just this promised land of like hey
i've got a button that gets me sex
whenever i want it because uh it's an
app of like-minded horny [ __ ] men and
it felt like we'd got that we had a
great night and then i remember like the
morning afterward i asked her at the
moment i went can i have your number and
she just went
why
you don't live here i'm not coming to
scotland and i was like
oh my god
yeah i couldn't [ __ ] believe it and
then like she kissed me goodbye and i
was like can i
come see you later she's like no go it's
done i was like oh my god and like that
was tinder from my experience like
whenever i went to america and
the uk and stuff was just i would keep
meeting uh
women who were just very similar along
the lines of hey let's get here for
three days let's have fun for three days
you know it's like the perfe i always
argued that was like the perfect uh what
a relationship is you get three days of
all the last all the attraction and all
the sex but without them learning all of
your flaws without you learning all of
their flaws and in the future like you
know 20 years down the line when she's
married and have kids and she's having a
rough day she can fondly reminisce to
the time that we were in denver colorado
together she got her head back
yeah you know through a headboard by uh
by a comedian and then i could look back
and it's this perfect memory you know in
in in the past and then
you start getting all the [ __ ] you
know and then everyone started finding
out about tinder and then you start
getting all the
i'm not here for a one night stand [ __ ]
and you're like get off the [ __ ] half
then
this is the one night stand up you
[ __ ] [ __ ] how [ __ ] we were having
these are our people this was our place
you have come into our sacred place and
you've ruined it yeah yeah and i know
men ruined that i know it was i know it
was my [ __ ] team being creepy and
weird and like you know there was a
golden time when it was just all the fun
people it was like rare you ever heard
of [ __ ] rare no oh right so right oh
let me tell you about this it's the
famous tinder right there's a celebrity
tinder okay right so you've got to be
like [ __ ] verified on i think it's
like twitter and instagram and episode
and you've got to like send them your
profile and they decide if you're
verified to get on yeah yeah
[Laughter]
told me about it like six or seven years
ago okay um
and and i was adding and it's like man
it's better it's celebrity tinder so
it's like they're it's just they're
awesome
kardashian tonight do i fancy a cummings
do a fantasy or whatever
[ __ ] you know yeah oh god jesus christ
there are a lot of mps
on the female section thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace
you